training for police officers is totally
insufficient 20 of the time that they
work they should be training right now
it's probably not even a measurable
percentage of time that they're working
probably in the fractions of a percent
that they're training they get horrible
training they're in really dynamic
situations doing an incredibly hard job
you talk about the misconceptions of the
street fight is the person that thinks
if someone messes with me i'm just gonna
get wild that's not gonna work
especially against someone that's
trained if you think you're gonna have
some magical powers because you're angry
or cause your adrenaline's going that's
not true it's gonna cost you in a big
way especially if you come up against
somebody like tim kennedy who's
genuinely trained a lot of people train
if you get no fight in san diego there's
a decent chance you're fighting against
someone that knows how to fight there's
jujitsu academies every street in san
diego yeah if you just think you're
gonna be a tough guy it's gonna be a
rough tour